when we was hanging out don king's no no
no no oh
forget it
what's wrong with me
what is that like oh
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot box and i'm evan britton
and i'm mike tyson dude mike we got the
man in here today big time big time this
show is going to get
pretty views man after this it's going
to be exciting
welcome
dude great to have you here yeah happy
to be here man you know what man
it's amazing i mean let's tell them
let's start off with the beginning first
yeah go to the
ancestors okay so tell us um being for
queens right right what made you decide
to be a rapper what
where did it all start i mean it all
started because um
you know honestly i i just felt um you
know growing up in queens you feel
like almost forgotten you know what i'm
saying um
you know and i just felt like that was
the first time i ever heard brothers
being powerful i never heard black men
be powerful before i never heard them
talk
with pride and power and strength and
when i first heard treacherous three
phyllis ford crash crew
um you know africa bambada zulu nation
when i first heard that wave of rap
rappers come in it just was the first
time that i heard somebody say something
that was empowering like that you know
because when you're growing up in the
hood you almost feel forgotten
you know what i'm saying it's like you
you almost there's a part of you that
wants to hide that's why you see people
walking like this they're kind of being
tough
but they're kind of hiding a little bit
from everything that's going on and it
was like
that was the first time i heard people
open up you know what i'm saying and be
powerful so i wanted to be a part of
that
you know having tough times with my
step-pops tough times with different
people in my life
you know it was just um it was really
just an energizing
time for me does that make sense you
know pretty much so yeah who's the first
guy that really you made you give you
the
idea that i could be this sometimes we
look at guys that give us that
and um give us that light and say wow
that's that's inspiring but how do i get
that
you know when i first heard the cold
crush yeah um i was a little kid
and um cold crush brothers rap you know
one of the founder fathers of hip-hop
uh you know the guys in my neighborhood
used to be like yo
i would like imitate them and then they
was like yo you got a good voice let me
hear you do that again
you know they was like oh you sound good
imitate them some more so i would
imitate them some more and then
after a while around like 11 or 12 i
started writing my own rhymes
writing my own lyrics and um the rest is
history you know what i'm saying wow he
must have saw m.c
said [ __ ] them
he's the first rapper that started
coming to the fights
oh that's funny i didn't know i didn't
know that but yeah see i wasn't exposed
to shannon like that back then it was
really about the groups that came out of
the bronx and harlem
um i don't know how long shan was doing
it prior to that but uh for me it was
it was it was treacherous it was
fearless it was it was you know
obviously anybody affiliated with zulu
it was you know it was all of those
artists flash
you know treacherous three modi all of
them you know cool
yeah all them tapes was coming through
and that was enjoy record sugar hill
records you know what i'm saying like
those were the
between the tapes and those labels
between sugar hill and joy lady b from
philly
the queen had queen had this sound i
remember they had roxanne sean tate yeah
yeah well that was later yeah
so later on yeah shantae shan marley
mall all of that that was much later
um but definitely queens was represented
even before that you had
you know dj devon you had the disco
twins you had infinity machine which was
like groups that was like that was
expected yes yes you are yeah
yes yes exactly
exactly yeah when did you guys meet
you're about the same age right yeah
what do you
um i don't know we you know we hung out
a lot of times because i used to just
come you know wherever you was at we'd
hang out and i'd be like yo champ yo
mike what up
and um i think we it was a some kind of
lunch like a restaurant
right and you had a limousine you
remember and i came out
yeah yeah yeah you had a you had a
limousine
and a and it was at a restaurant or
something some girls or something i came
to hang out with you and we was chilling
and
you know he was riding around in a limo
and yeah it was
yeah it was and i don't know like and
then you had shorty black with you at
that time i mean
shorty's from my hood i know you from
your neighborhood he's from my
neighborhood you know he was you know
i'm like all those guys remember all
those guys used to be out there
prince and those yeah yeah of course
prince used to be in brownsville
ah that's how i knew but i didn't know
about all the supreme
court but yeah that's the [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah rolling back yeah oh yeah
that's justin they were rolling no
question no question
divine prince yes they know what i'm
saying you know what i'm saying
um shorty you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah that's the hook money bumps and all
those guys guys too
one up peace peace shout out it's dope
man
i was born in new york city lived in
brooklyn until i was 10 and my mom moved
my
me and my brother out here to l.a okay
but we talk about all the time how many
people from
new york that area are just
like but why are you starting why is it
new york since the beginning really why
is it not new york why
everybody comes and why they need right
they get that spark the boom yeah
the world about you you know you know
new york was i think
you know for many many years new york
has been the center of the universe when
it comes to
yeah you know just things happen in the
united states whether it's capitalism
the whole yankee new york mentality that
new york hustle was just something that
was very real it's not to
to to like minimize any other states or
any other parts of
the world or america but new york that
new york hustle is a real thing you know
what i'm saying and i think
that idea that if you can make it there
you can make it anywhere it's surreal
that's some real [ __ ]
that's very real because like you know
if you go to hollywood you go to
entertainment
everybody knows everybody hey my cousin
know you my cousin used to hang out my
cousin's dead now but he was locked up
with you whoa
really yeah he knows everybody knows
everybody that's true
it's a neighborhood no doubt yeah
well when was your first big break with
music
first big break with music was um
actually
you know when i was 14 i started trying
to make a record right so i started
sending demos out at age 14. i started
writing at 12 11 to 12 14 i started
sending out demos
when i turned 16 i sent a demo into rick
rubin there was a record out called it's
yours by t leroy it's yours
and um i sent a um demo into rick rubin
um actually ad rocker the beastie boys
heard the demo first
he heard the demo adrock of the beastie
boys and he liked it and he played it
for rick
and um when he played it for rick rick
called me i went in
we were he had a dorm room at nyu you
know what i'm saying five university
place you know what i'm saying i
remember going down there i'm doing
handstands on the subway and [ __ ]
because i was so happy not for real
literally doing handstands on the subway
so happy that i'm going to
rick ruby call me this dick so i went
down
and um i remember rick walked downstairs
to the dome and when he came down in the
dorm
he said he said i said yo rick he said
yeah i said i thought you was black
he said cool yeah we went up and we went
upstairs
and we started working on demos and um
the rest is history we made this thing
called catch this break
on this demo and when we made this demo
code catch this break we
immediately as soon as we were done went
across town it was like midtown
somewhere and got with russell simmons
and played it for him
and russell was like oh it's the same
old thing treacherous three crowds same
old thing
rick was like really so me and rick went
back in the studio i made this joint
call i need a beat
russell heard it and they decided to
start the label def jam
and uh once they started the label def
jam i was the label def jam not the
production company which tila rock was
on but the label
i was the first artist on the label and
uh you know the rest of this history
yeah for real what i'm saying
i need my radio yeah radio came out yup
that was my first album yup
yuck man you were 16 16 years old man
wow
16. all right so dick tell me this when
did y'all
you have to go back to the celebrity but
when did your family tell you about your
your family it's your famous family oh
the boxing so what happened was
i went i went to um everybody knows
finding your roots is this show
with henry lewis gates you know
professor gates and um
you know i just you know in that show
you got a guy
mike you gotta go it's amazing and um
shout out to um
skip gates professor gates love you man
um so
i went you know just normal thing and
i'm thinking okay we're going to find
out because you know
you know my mother yeah yeah i'm gonna
find out
all the normal stuff so we go in and um
you know he does the research and then
he calls me up and he's like well where
was your father where's your mother from
where's your girl
and it turns out push come to make a
long story short my mother was actually
adopted
and we didn't know so then i'm like okay
then we find out that my real family you
know half of the family were weren't
slaves they you know it got free and
were free and then the other
and then we started doing he started
digging deeper and finding out
all of this information um about my my
boxing family my my history like i'd
always love boxing from
you know i mean just naturally my second
album cover i'm hitting a heavy bag like
in 87 like
i've always loved it like this is not
like an act it's not like oh you know
this is real like yeah the boxing thing
is real for me like i really love it and
enjoy it for
real yeah um i like the spirit of it you
know i don't think it's about being
tough
it's about the spirit you know i'm
saying boxing is a spirit
the toughness comes out tough guys don't
do good exactly
exactly that's my point it's a very it's
the spirit
you know what i mean fighting spirit
it's the spirit so i i like
you know i always love that about it and
um
come to find out that you know my
grandfather was a boxer
nathaniel christie lewis and his um my
uncle
was a is actually a light the first
black light heavyweight champion
in america john john henry lewis
first ever lineal champion light
heavyweight champion not just
a belt holder like a lineal light
heavyweight champion first black lineal
light heavyweight champion
and then through through um john henry
lewis
and he you know found out in his in my
new family that or well my family i
didn't know about
tom molino is another ancestor who was a
a bare-knuckle champion
because you won't i'll tell him who he
was tom yeah tell him tell him to tell
him about him tell him about it
amazing i mean tom allen know crying
yeah he got his freedom
um i mean yeah tell them tell them it's
amazing tom
mononok probably in the 1890s it was
against the 1990s
1790s right yeah he was the best slave
fighter in america nobody in america on
the slave plantation could beat them
yeah and he wanted freedom but you don't
understand that this is
people won their freedom he won his
freedom is his
his owner gave him 500 in 18 and 1700s
late 1700s and that's why
that's why you know when you look at the
history that's why my mother's side of
the family there's no slavery there's no
history of slavery because
thomas molino got us free you know what
i'm saying so yeah
and he went to he went and after that
didn't he no let me continue yeah yeah
go ahead
and after that he beat all the stuff he
can't fight slave no he's not a slave no
more
yeah so he beat all the american free
fighters
he beat them all he's the first slave
that could beat everybody in the country
the slave [ __ ] he's a slave yeah he
sleeps on the floor
he can beat every man in a fair fight in
america
yeah yeah yeah so it's like you know and
going through my uncle john
so they called for him to come to all
over he beat everybody in australia he
beat everybody
so they come from to be the greatest
fighter they've known since the
beginning of england
his name is tom cripp right yeah the
greatest
and this is what he don't normal but
napoleon bet fox
put a bunch of money on his uncle's
great uncle napoleon's
the slave master who hates black don't
believe in
black republic he bet all he been around
a couple of thousand dollars on your
on your great great uncle that's crazy
the big [ __ ]
so he doesn't bonaparte yes so um
he then he's having a [ __ ] with no
problem so he's beating cribbing the
english people getting worried they
crack them over here with an iron pipe
what yeah yeah and they let [ __ ] beat
them and they don't stop the fight
yeah they're doing it wide open it's
open it's not nothing like
it's wide open he's a black man he's a
black man he has no rights
he's going to beat the greatest fighter
of our ever thomas no way
yeah we're going to stop him and they
got sketches of this too this is this
actual event
there's a there's actually shorts that
wrote it so it's not me being favoritism
towards the black guy so they wrote it
okay yeah yeah
so i'm just going back from what they
said you can google it you can do it
from that right he was so depressed he
turned into an alcoholic and stuff
yeah he died he died in ireland he died
in ireland after
you know and knowing that through my
uncle john him yeah that's that's him
right there that's
what he wants he's um
he's gave so much inspiration for
fighters from that time on in generals
and stuff like that
it's amazing it's unbelievable so many
people asked me to play him before i've
been asked so many times that's what i
wanted
you could totally yeah england asked me
to play this guy
and i was staying and that's before i
knew he was your cousin and then dennis
told me about it before
wow and i said you know that's ella
who's a relative he says
that would be awesome story tom
marlanuke yeah you know what i mean
that would be an incredible story this
is tom look right here yeah
tomorrow no it's so amazing and then you
go from him
you go to my uncle john henry my
grandfather you know john henry
um you know john henry lewis you know
he's a heavyweight champion john henry
lewis
he he he never lost a light heavyweight
title fight he only lost to joe lewis
and joe lewis knocked him out and he was
going blind
he did it for money he did it for money
his friend you know
exactly but did you notice all this but
he didn't know that he didn't know um
you didn't know
this guy was a lady killer in the 30s
did you well i would i would assume so
he looks just like my mother in the
picture on the right hand lower right
hand corner he looks first
like my mother yeah yo that right there
he looks
almost like my mother is crazy
yeah yeah it's crazy that's crazy right
yeah yeah
but look he's still you still got the
health mentality that's good
family bloodline you're conscious of
your health he was kind he was a fine
dressing [ __ ] you didn't know
that either no i didn't know that oh get
him dressed up
try to find him in dress clothes he was
beautiful all the women loved them back
here yeah yeah
they all noticed he was loved man look
at him right there joe
look at his cashmere coat look at him
right here yeah yeah look at him
look at that look how beautiful he is
waves he was fresh that boy was fresh
that's him look at the one with him
winking go back back
up go with the one with the winking
right there look at him wait wait yeah
no go down somewhere this it doesn't
make you but i know this must make you
proud
yeah it does man it does look look at
him right there yeah yeah with the yeah
yeah
yeah on his way overseas he's probably
going he's on a boat right here he's
going on his way overseas yup
he felt jim brady for all the great
fighting actually rosenbaum great
fighting yeah yeah i'm all beat them all
yep yep this is my uncle man and you
know
finding this out was the craziest thing
in the world because you know i had no
idea man i just always loved the spirit
of the boxing
spirit that's why i made mama said knock
you out and all these yeah i always just
love that that vibe and then
to discover this was like mama yo i love
the screen this [ __ ] is crazy like
right here right now yeah bro that's how
we do [ __ ]
man look at him man yeah it's amazing
man that's amazing history
yeah it is and lineage you know i want
to shout it out to the whole lewis
family
my uh joan and everybody you know what
i'm saying absolutely everybody
did you get to after you found out all
this did you get to connect with
somebody oh yeah
oh yeah i connected with everybody
that's awesome connected with everybody
um uh my my aunt jones she was like
actually one of the first female black
panthers you know yeah
yeah yeah she was uh she was um you know
female recruit you know what i'm saying
as a young girl it's a young 15 16 year
old girl
first people to go out there give out
school lunches people this is what i
noticed too
this is before i met you and how did
they end up in los angeles where they
originated
they were born in los angeles well they
came from ohio
they came from ohio and ended up in the
bay area yeah you know what i'm saying
they just
want to have arizona really i thought he
was in this no nothing how did he get in
seattle they were from in seattle for a
while
that i don't know about i know that they
were in they were in arizona they were
in ohio and they ended up in the bay
area seattle i don't know about it
where he's from where he's come from
yeah yeah i know he was in seattle for a
while yeah
what's his name says berkeley yeah yeah
berkeley california yeah they ended up
in the bay area born in phoenix
yeah they went from arizona um did some
some stuff in ohio
and ended up in the bay area yeah yeah
yeah and um look 117
fights that's a lot of fights man no
that's that's not
they don't have it all that's the fight
that they counted wow
yeah yeah you know that's what they they
[ __ ] up a lot on the numbers and stuff
back then yeah
you ain't even caught by the damage no
footage of him fighting yeah
none i can't fight femme fighting who um
tom
tom tommy milani tommy mclaughlin it's
got tommy lonegan
yo he's gotta have fun the only footage
you see is getting beat by joe lewis
and that's when he's an old man he's
sick and [ __ ] yeah that's the only fight
that i find
everything i saw a fighter i got to be a
fighter i thought i'm fighting before
but you had you used to have all those
films right yeah do you have any of that
stuff no i don't have that stuff now but
got to be on this thing
yeah he was he was a he was a beast man
master boxers smooth boxer yeah master
box
yeah
orthodox orthodox stance you know what
i'm saying
working without everything for everybody
yeah
you know i love you know i just think
boxing in general you know when i go
back to like
when i think about jack johnson and i
think about you know
you know all of the guy what he did you
know even jack johnson i mean
you got to really respect the craft you
know what i'm saying like you got to
respect that craft like
you know you think about all of the
different guys that he fought um
willard was it jess willard williams
yeah ready for you for jess willie what
um
what's the guy jim jeffrey jim jeffries
that's the guy he took the title from
right that's that was the greatest
champion of all time before johnson came
on the scene he was chairman for six
years
beat everybody undefeated and then they
brought him back he retired and johnson
won the title and he brought him back
and he beat him and he beat 15 rounds he
beat him he beat him yeah it was uh
you know i think about sugar ray
robinson i think about you know
um even like guys like max bear you know
what i'm saying jewish champion
you know he was killing guys in the ring
tough yeah he wasn't a good fighter he
was just big strong
punch like hell yeah but then you're
running with the math the [ __ ] you
running the guy that you can't
hit [ __ ] yeah yeah like fighting a guard
you can't
ghost yeah you can't hit a [ __ ] you're
like [ __ ]
you hit hard but you can't hit him
because you can't hit him
[Laughter]
he's a human being he got a body he's
big why can't i hit him
you can't even kick him if you were
allowed to kick you couldn't hit him
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so you know i think
about you know the boxing man there's
something about that
that craft you know and all the
difference the different types of styles
you know
the head movement the people that are
good with the torso the people with
footwork
the complete fighters like sugar ray who
can do footwork and
upper body work you know you know sugar
ray you know robinson would you know
throw left to the body um you know uh
left to the body
and then faker left it about boom you
get caught with like a you know
a hook you know what i'm saying yeah but
then sometimes you run into some guys
you know
and then yeah you're just cool and
you're cooling your head and boom boom
boom
and they just looking at you yeah and
then coming back
yeah after you hit them no you know you
didn't hit them you ended with
everything
that's when you that's when you got to
say to yourself i'm going after points
yes
that's when you got to say i'm cool i'm
pointing let me think because i'll be
out of because you'll you'll drain
yourself yeah you'll drain yourself
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you train yourself this
is going the distance we're going the
distance in this
yeah yeah that's why fighting our league
no one no one i know when they fought
our lead no one went in there thinking
for going for a knockout we know we're
getting 15 rounds
yeah the only one who's trying to do
that frazier yeah you're hating him he
wants to knock him on
frasier but frazier that's why frasier
would at the end of
you know even though uh mohammed was
tired too frazier was like that because
frazier was always trying to kill him
he's trying to kill some yeah you know
what i'm saying um
yeah yo frasier i leave the monk yeah
but ali was a monster too no doubt but
frazier was something else
like when you see me push he push right
he pushed alley to that limit man
the elevation of yes where you don't
feel anything where you
transcend when you're outside your body
and you're just fighting and that's a
prime example of styles making fights
because when you think about when you
think about frasier and then you think
about foreman and then you think about
ali
that's a prime example of styles making
fights big right
forming forming a knockout frasier
norton 10 times out of 10 times they
fight right
frasier and norton will fight our league
they give him life to death fights ali
almost having a heart attack right yep
forming fights with ali ali kills him
right
exactly these guys fight with ali they
give holly a heart attack
exactly that's crazy that's a prime
example of styles make sense
prime example prime example you know
what i'm saying that really matters
it's how your bodies lock in it's almost
like you know i don't mean to be weird
but it's almost like
sex you know what i'm saying like you
get with a certain girl
there's a connection there that's
difficult you know what i mean it's like
this one someone told me yeah all [ __ ]
the same that's [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's not
yeah my father used to tell oh you bet
it over at all looks to say
no
i think men said that back then the
hartman for the reason they didn't want
us to know that they lost to the [ __ ]
exactly
they stay tough it's all the same but
why
is it all the same why did i stick with
this one if it's all the same why did i
stick with this one
why am i not going after [ __ ] them
all
with that kind of idea in life they're
gonna lose in relationships it's all the
same that's [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah we all submit to it and
then we all submit to it well you know
that's a choice it's called humanity
that's true you're also meant to
humanity that's true and any man that's
not afraid of that wife not living their
life right
yeah you can't be living your life but
you're not afraid of her
[Laughter]
you're not paying your wife no no no if
you're not giving me your life yeah
i i i'm living fairly right i guess you
know what i'm saying
i mean i guess it's all relative yeah
when she goes in that door and she's not
feeling well whoa
your house is [ __ ] up that's that's
that's true [ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah
if i come in the house not feeling well
should talk to me we can take care of
that
but the house when they're messed up you
can't talk to them yeah you know
you got to do [ __ ] to make them happy
hell you have kids
yeah yeah i got four four kids you have
teenagers yeah yeah my kids are
older my kids are from 20 and 28 from
yeah yeah down to
18. yeah yeah i have four kids yeah
that's crazy what does it what does it
like
do they they have kids or anything yet
um my daughter does
my daughter my mother it's amazing yeah
it's amazing i'm waiting for that day i
want that day to happen it's amazing man
because you know you think about lineage
you think about legacy you know what i'm
saying you think about
you know plus it's it doesn't mean that
you can't
continue to maximize your potential you
know what i'm saying so it's uh
it's a beautiful thing you know i'm
saying especially if you start off like
i did
you know you know i had my son was born
when i
damn near the beginning of my career you
know what i'm saying so my kids have
kind of
two of my kids that's kind of awesome
though yeah they grew up with my
with my career you know i'm saying i had
kids early you know what i'm saying
and they grew up with me so it's like um
not grow up with me but grow up with my
career
yeah um so it's been um it's amazing i'm
grateful you know man i'm grateful man
very good look at all the great
successful families love my kids even in
some biblical time but ancient times as
well they always had a lot of kids
because they always look at um
the synopsis or the um what can't go
wrong will go on people will die people
will go to war people would get sick
so we lost that to a lot of kids yeah
the crisis we might be jews we might be
black that'll kill us
so we have to make sure we have a lot of
kids well you want to you want to look i
always see the positives and always see
positive energy but i definitely
wanted to you know have a family i think
that you know
part of being a man is making sure that
you have that lineage and you can
you know you can provide not just
financially but you can provide
emotionally spiritually and then at the
same time you can bring strength
and integrity and power to you to your
family as well and
teach them to be greater than they than
they even think is possible
and instilling them the belief that they
can do anything they put their minds to
you know what i'm saying that's part of
manhood
you know part of being a real man is you
know not just taking care of your family
but instilling
the values and the that that spirit in
your kids that
tells them that they can take their
lives to the highest levels possible
you know what i'm saying that's part of
being a real man what do you tell your
kids tell me this what do you tell your
kids
when your kids see on television all
these [ __ ] white cops are killing
black kids what are you talking how do
you how do you confront how do you
tell you why are they killing us daddy
what do you do wrong daddy well my kid
my kids are a little older so i haven't
had to have that conversation but my
thing is this look um
the majority of that is hate and fear
base do you tell them who they are
oh without a doubt yes they're kings and
queens and they got to love themselves
and you got to be proud to be who you
are like i'm very proud to be a black
man like i'm not
shying away from that i'm not trying to
be anything other than that you know
what i'm saying when i walk in the room
i'm a black man at the same time i'm not
i'm not going to be defined by that in
other words like i don't see a white guy
and say okay well
there's an automatic separation but i
know who i am and i'm proud of who i am
my consciousness supersedes my color
someone told me well without a doubt and
your character right martin luther king
talked about that and your spirit spirit
is beyond all of that but when you talk
on an earthly level when you talk on an
earthly level
you got to know who you are and you got
to you got to know your identity and you
got to be willing to you know
handle that straight up so what i would
say when i think about what's going on
with
the police and well the bad cops you
know saying not all of them but the bad
ones that are doing that
that's fair and hey you know what i'm
saying you got some people that are so
concerned with that they just believe
that they're dying they believe that
they're going away they believe that
they don't have a future
so they want to stop others you know
what i'm saying i believe that
you know what i mean i believe that yeah
you know what i'm saying like it's it's
it's like you know the whole idea that's
a peep game right
i watch youtube a lot of junkie right so
i watch youtube and i notice um
this cop comes over he puts this black
kid over he pulls him out
smacks me throws him in the [ __ ] car
right right i'm thinking this is just a
racist ass cracker right right
that's cool i'm accustomed to that this
is interesting this is show business i'm
watching this he smacks him
but he still looks around he's got the
guy in the car but another car comes out
he goes in the car he grabs the car the
young white girl he grabs out
he smacks then he grabs the black guy
get the [ __ ] throw and he said well
it's his daughter oh wow it's his
daughter so i'm like whoa right
and i'm saying that's the biggest fear
well well yeah of course well that's the
whole idea right like
like i mean let's be real the the real
story that no one's talking about with
the with the like the abortion thing
like i believe women should have the
right to choose what they want
but let me tell you but the women should
definitely have look it's her body let
her choose what she wants right
if i was a woman you're gonna tell me to
have your baby [ __ ] you're crazy
but but but that being said i think that
that's really about
what that's really about is is white
supremacy it's like
a belief that you know what our race is
going to go away if we let these women
have abortions
check this out this is interesting
exactly so hopefully a whole bunch of
brothers don't go running down to
alabama
that's not gonna happen that's not gonna
happen know what's gonna happen they're
gonna come up here and say no we need
some black men
you know because the fact is why do they
have um
in the white neighborhood they have um
these drugs that make you have babies
what's that called again
oh yeah no they give you babies
fertility fertility growth and then
black neighborhood they had planned
praise
planned parenthood yeah they don't have
planned parenthood in beverly hills are
you [ __ ] crazy
that's interesting no it's just that the
monaco yeah france they don't have it
out there planned parenthood they want
to have people because
the race is decreasing right you know
and and and minorities multiply like
rabbits these guys
these guys are dying which they're dying
with diseases
and they have [ __ ] babies all day
every day well you know i think
you know what i mean you know what you
just said i'm saying these people are
sick these people are healthy and can't
have it
i think it's exactly what you guys are
saying how do you think we get all these
in our community but i can't stop babies
but i think i think the key though
though the whole thing is
at the end of the day it's just fear you
know what i'm saying at the end of the
day we all have fear
this is a fear-based work but that but
that particular thing is you have people
that are making decisions based in fear
we all have fears but the difference is
when you're courageous you have fear and
you move forward anyway right
because you're courageous so even though
you feel the fear you can move forward
whereas you have some people that are
making their decisions based on fear
yeah and when they make their decisions
based on fear that creates situations
like
you know women aren't allowed to have
abortions and you know and
a disregard for for the female spirit
yeah
you see what i'm saying so i i think
that that that whole
you know white supremacy thing is kind
of fueling that you know what i'm saying
it's kind of fueling that
underneath and it's it's not something
that anybody's ever probably going to
admit unless you go to some certain
websites on it on them
online they're not going to admit it but
i feel like that has such an effect on
essentially bringing up that they have
such an effect on us
white supremacy it has such an effect on
us that we think
in a white supremacist perspective i
know what you mean right
yeah if you've been programmed we are
programming we are progressing right now
i don't care how conscious you mean
we're programmed we are number one you
got to break it down yeah that's why
we have something don't think we ain't
these that's what that's why when the
bible says
be i'm strengthened by the renewing of
your mind and you can even say that
reading the bible is a program
and yes we are programmed but the thing
is the thing is
what kind of mind do you have do you
have a mind that can go outside of the
normal paradigms you have a mind that
can break out beyond
whatever parameters that have been set
for you so that you can see things
differently
because it's you know it's it's the
whole idea of of
you know like deja vu is seeing
something that
um something new that seems familiar and
then there's vujo day right seeing
something familiar in a new way
you know what i'm saying and my thing is
that so what we have to do is we have to
look at our day
yeah you got to see things familiar
things in a new way so yeah
yeah there's there's the programming
there's the you know people that want to
teach you to hate yourself
people that t but you got to see things
in a new way familiar things in a new
way
so you can go beyond that you know what
i mean you know i look at um
this is what i think when you say i look
at this i think this like i might be
weird [ __ ] i go like this right
i was doing some research on this guy
what was his name
he was um he was down with um he was um
dumas he was down with napoleon
alexander the black trimmer yeah he was
the black count yeah he was down with
dumas but yeah he was down with um
napoleon but he was down with louis xiii
first before he died they killed lou um
to him and his wife wasn't yeah again
antoinette yeah maria he was down with
that crew too
and so i said wow black [ __ ]
down when they're pulling in these guys
and it's history if henry's family then
she's the haitian guy originally yeah
yeah yeah
i said well i'm interested i want to
know about this guy so i look around
look at him
i come down to the 30s and the 40s his
families are in the olympics
for fencing they no longer do monsters
they name my oppenheimers
and you know what's even deeper his son
ended up being a writer oh those that's
news that's old stuff
yeah he had three sons one was the
writer one was the play-off yeah
but first it was alexander dumas fritz i
think it was alexander dumas
maybe junior but it was three or four of
them the sun the son was
very famous one of the sons was the one
who wrote all the plays alexander dumas
yeah but the the father his
he was the black count he was a general
in the polls
crystal is his story it's based on him
the black count there's a book out
called the black count that really talks
about
the um alexander dumas the general i
read that book and yeah i read it too i
read it too it
was it was on the black count and it was
it's an unbelievable story about
you know this guy who was a general a
black general in napoleon's army and
when i say a general he had a whole
division
and um he was like unbelievable and he'd
rush into battle with a sword and
[ __ ] everybody up and he was people you
know he was smart
now you say that though but then you
then you go down history and you get
back into the
20th century now his family in the
olympics and their fencers
right in that trip yeah they had the
bloodline if the
general would have swore leaning with us
what now the fencing champions yeah
olympics
yeah yeah he was someone who want to be
on the show hopefully hear me calling
the abrahamic family
that related to him the dumas family i
wish they hear me on my
ipod and come down yeah and they're
getting in prison towards the end too
they they betrayed him oh yeah
they traded him yeah he was jealous he
was jealous of him
he was jealous of those haitian
revolutionaries too yeah
yeah yeah dessaline and what's the uh
tasantla overture he was so jealous of
me he was such a little small guy
yeah yeah vitality he was so jealous of
them toussaint elovator was very crafty
and clever yeah it was very clever and
crappy but he made a mistake by trusting
his white slave master that's one thing
he would never hurt them and it was this
guy named platonix that was saying he
was a white guy but he said kill all the
whites
and he wouldn't do that he liked the
white people that treated him nice he
wouldn't kill him and so tom said you're
going to pay for that
so napoleon had i want to have a meeting
with you so he got on
the boat to go have a meeting and they
they lied and they put him in chains and
he starved them to death
and one of the worst one of the worst
mistakes the worst mistake you can make
i always tell my team this
the worst mistake you can make is one
from kindness oh absolutely
you know what i'm saying the worst
mistake you can make is one out of
kindness
trying to be nice because if you didn't
know if you're ignorant that's one thing
if you're stupid that's one thing if
they fool you that's another thing
but to make a mistake trying to be nice
oh you feel oh
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] there's nothing worse
than that
that's the word yo make a mistake out of
kindness
you know peace comes dick war dicks
takes peace yeah though it's always been
that war is going to dictate peace it
does
it does and now now here's the thing
though walk
does it can it can definitely set up
peace but it doesn't necessarily always
have to be physical war
sometimes it can be psychological and
mental but war does precede peace
it's the war we're going on right now
it's scary because right now
minorities are starting to figure things
out with this stuff
yeah with the internet we're starting to
figure things out we're starting to
figure out how we got it who we were if
you ever do the history
of what are those kind of what does
women call
mulatto women if you do oh you become a
bitter [ __ ]
and really know the history of mulatto
women's and what they did in new orleans
and how they treated them and what they
did in korea
yeah and how these people had families
and when it was time to have their
their [ __ ] i want to say they had
they they're not the
orgy balls and stuff you have to leave
your family and go and participate in
the rg bar
um you know yeah yeah and then go back
to your husband and your family like
nothing ever happened yeah
well you know that that's you know you
know about our power dictates the rules
man
exactly and that's why um the world is
really frightening now because we're
getting the consciousness of power
it's going to change we change yeah and
the 20 listen we can't really change the
way we eat food
the way we eat food is about to change
the way we smoke cigarettes are about to
change
you know i mean we're going to live
longer and that's going to be even
frightening
more frightening for some yeah so oh no
the power of the bee is gonna be more
frightening unless they control the
people that
that's living longer but you know it
look
at the end of the day there is room for
i think
certain forms of reconciliation and love
you know love is a key factor in all of
this right like
don't get me wrong i'm not saying that
you you you put love in there and you're
going to love your way through a war
i'm just saying that i'm saying that
love has a place
you know i'm saying and it's not only
about division it's not
only about fear it's about faith it's
about believing in yourself it's about
seeing the the beauty and the character
of other people too because
we always must remember that even with
everything that we're talking about
there are always people on both sides
that are trying to come together
it's not always a bunch of people trying
to separate themselves from each other
there's always people on the other side
who are saying you know what i love you
the same way you love me and we have to
remember that
because if not we'll we'll we'll speak
division
into our world and it will only you know
end up crumbling into
a a a seeping pool of negativity how do
you define love though
i think i think love you know it's funny
you know it's that old saying right like
like if you're in the desert love is
water right
if you you know if you're on a you know
a freezing mountaintop love is heat
you know you know love is the
appropriate response you know what i'm
saying but it's
you know there's a difference between
it's not always romantic love and it's
always
not always nice love i'll give you an
example if you're in the civil war and
you know the level of medicine
love is sawing a guy's leg off because
you know by sowing your leg off i'm
giving you the best chance to
to live so love is not always pleasant
but love is but love is a real thing you
know love is
is real it's not always pleasant but
it's
but love is appropriate love is the
appropriate response
in the in the moment you know i'm saying
love could be you know
doing away with with one enemy for the
greater good of our society
love can be many things you know that's
what love is so
why is it called love you dude well i
think those are those are just english
words right those are the terms i mean
you get back to there's all kind of love
you go back to the ancient greek and you
have like different
forms of love that they talk about
romantic love
love between family family love love but
you know there's different
i think terms like there's you can make
finer distinctions in
the category of love but ultimately you
know
love is what's needed you know what i'm
saying it's total commitment pretty much
it is it
is total commitment to the appropriate
and necessary thing whatever that thing
is i think at the moment
i think that's whatever it is you know
you know yeah total commitment there's
an
ineffability of the energy of it of the
power
it's something you can't really put into
words yeah true
yeah what you're talking about l what
i'm talking you know
love the love that can carry people
through a war
the love that can love of country love
of country
love of family what you're doing love of
yourself
well you know it goes back to that you
know and just to flip it but but it goes
back to
i don't know it was a courtroom
proceeding and someone had asked this
judge he said you know it's like kind of
like porn
you you know you can't really describe
it but you know when you see it
you know what i mean you know you know
you know it when you see it
so love you know it when you see it if
we're you know if we're in a war
and our technological advancements have
taken us to a certain level and
we're in the civil war times and i saw
your leg off you know it's love because
you know what i'm trying to do yeah but
you know what i'm saying listen but even
that when you say
i know when i see they used to do
enrollment time porn with
[ __ ] open in the street you can screw
your slaves you can have sex with your
wife
with a man you can do anything in the
street how is anybody getting anything
done
yeah how was that you know because it
got time didn't exist
time is made by men it was just life
we're living right right well there's
different types of time right there's
kairos
there's an appointed time there's
there's all kinds of time had to be made
to create civilization before it was
just madness
well you know what's funny about time
einstein said that the only reason that
we have time is so everything doesn't
happen at once
and i thought that that was a very
interesting way of looking at it because
if there was no time
everything would happen at once you know
what i'm saying so i thought that that
was interesting you know
that's interesting you know perspective
and perception
that's true yeah that's absolutely
because if you what did they say
if you if you if you're holding your
favorite woman time moves really
really really quickly but if you put
your hand on on a hot
on a hot frying pan time feels like
forever yeah so
yeah time is relative and there is a a
certain you know
you feel what i'm saying yeah the
relative yeah yeah it's crazy absolutely
well time is so interesting i mean it's
really just the flow of our
consciousness that
we've had to put something to yeah you
know listen
i took the toll there's no time there's
no space in there yeah the dmt right you
took the dna when you take there's no
time there's no space you're just there
and the [ __ ] just happening that you're
feeling
you ever hear about the toe
[Music]
oh god i'm dying [ __ ]
you don't exist but you do it
you do what you don't
die have to be glorious because life is
glorious
so life can be glorious and death wasn't
worth
[Music]
i experienced then um yeah nothing yeah
i heard about that i heard about that
dmt i heard that that's
it's really enlightening yeah you found
out there's nothing there right like you
you found out you're nothing you got
stripped away
i thought i know i don't know if i'm a
[ __ ] or not when you strip your ego oh
you're scared yeah yeah you don't see
anything you're not afraid not to get
yourself you're scared without your ego
your [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's happening unless unless you get
in debt unless you get past
it unless you get unless you get beyond
it to the actual spirit
oh your spirit has no fear no i'm saying
like i'll give you an example
how many times when you were fighting
and like you know you you iron mike
let's be real you i'm mike men feel you
all over the planet but how many times
were you afraid in the in the ring when
you went in every time
right so but you know what you fought
anyway yeah and when you when you got
past the ego in the front
back to the spirit yeah then you were
strong again you said i'm saying that so
the spirit the spirit gives you that
the spirit is what you want to tap into
the spirit is what you want to pay
attention to
exactly because some people have
different experiences than me they have
they go on journey i'm so
i'm so afraid i'm awesome yeah yeah
let's just go so fast
yeah i've been hearing about the dna
yeah
there's four people like you yeah yeah
it's for people like you it puts you in
your highest form of elevation
yeah you look at people and you look at
yourself totally different
yeah you know you know there's a god you
don't know his name
yeah but you know something that's
worthy of praying yeah i just don't want
to wake up with you know all leather on
with the red ball in my mind
shit's over did you like that [ __ ] no
you're gonna have to humble yourself
because you don't believe you're a god
after that
yeah yeah and you're gonna have to
control yourself yeah you know that's
powerful you're gonna say wow
yeah yeah all everything i thought my
whole life was a [ __ ] line
yeah yeah now i feel you okay that could
be phrased that could be frightening you
might love the way your life is now and
say wow
listen listen if i can unplug from the
matrix baby yeah i'm waiting
if i can unplug uh unplug me baby
unplugged
yeah if i can unplug for the matrix by
all means i accept it let you know that
things are bigger than you
absolutely not i love that i'm all for
that that i'm all for
you know man oh i think you're already
unplugged dude you're yeah you look like
you're
35. thanks man dude you take you've
taken great care of yourself
right thank you yeah yeah you feel good
yeah health fitness always been a big
why you never did a program
um you know whatever you know actually i
have no i have a couple of books out
there i have um a
couple of books platinum workout and i
have platinum 360 two workout books that
are out there that's on the madness they
saw you on this beautiful screen
i know they pumping and [ __ ]
i'm actually thinking about that i have
some money about getting you know maybe
opening up some gems at a certain point
i've been thinking about that and
considering that so
that's who you are [ __ ] the women
that come in and drove and the guy's
going to come for the game yeah
be crazy dude my college strength coach
went to arizona
played football he used to have us do
the ll med ball abs
oh yeah yeah yeah absolutely start on
your back yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah med ball sit up
absolutely absolutely to do those like
[ __ ] they were crazy they were yeah
they were they work
they work solid absolutely you have to
have a strong core
yeah you got to have a strong core
because for you to be the the best you
you could be you want to maximize your
potential right
and you you obviously you know about it
you're a fit guy and obviously mike i
mean yeah
it goes without saying so you want to
maximize your potential you got to be
strong you got to be the best you you
could possibly be
it's not about like trying to be 15 or
22 forever
it's about being the best thing that
best man that you could be your entire
life
you know what i'm saying that's what
it's about and being comfortable with
that
too embracing that not feeling like you
know not feeling
slighted not feeling like oh i'm older
but feeling being the best you you could
be
you know what i'm saying that's what i
respect when a man
says yo i'm gonna be the best me that i
could possibly be
you know what i'm saying maximize your
potential your potential
like i'm not gonna be your height i
don't need to be yeah because even
though you're taller than me i don't
feel short yeah you know what i'm saying
i gotta maximize my potential you know
what i'm saying and be the best me i can
be
you feel you feel what i'm saying so
that's what you want to do you know
feel that man yeah um you talked about
as a kid going to that meeting with rick
rubin doing handstands on the train
yeah so was training and working out
that was always part of your life it was
always because then i'll tell you the
real reason the real reason why i got
into fitness
straight up and down is because guys
would come home from jail and just be
huge
and then they'd be working out lifting
weights in the backyard and my man
norton and
they'd be in the front yard they make it
like that
drinking beer that's true all day it's
true
hold on bench out front just [ __ ] in
the front yard baby
i'm telling you running around with the
bb uh bvd nylons on
my man had the big chest i just really i
gotta get shake i gotta get shaved this
is crazy
everybody's running around looking
muscular you're like yo i gotta get in
shape
and it just it kind of inspires you i
know that is a positive that that comes
from a negative
yeah because obviously the jail culture
is a very it's negative right
you know anybody in jail tell you that
anybody who's been there tell you that
it's a negative you know i came to see
you when you were in jail it's a [ __ ] i
could see it in your eyes when i saw you
you know because we was like little kids
together almost and you was like first
thing you said to me is yo what are you
doing here
because you couldn't even associate me
with coming to see you in that
predicament
but i came to see you yeah i was happy
you didn't you know what i'm saying no
doubt man no doubt
so it's like it's like you know you
think about it i was like my man is in
here and i want to see him i want to
give him love you know what i'm saying
and
let him know that we still love him
regardless you know i mean so it's like
when i think about that that they're
they're positives that come from a tutor
like you don't be the strongest i can be
i want to be the best i can be
you know what i'm saying and that's what
it's about
yeah it's good yeah it's good stuff what
do you do these days you're training reg
um well you know it like yesterday it
was like a slow day in terms of training
so i did an hour on the elliptical
you know i i did intervals i i got my
heart rate elevated but i only did an
hour and then i took a shower and rested
but then there are other days where i do
i always do cardio and weights
and then i hit the heavy bag because um
but i hit the heavy bag more for
mental focus clarity some endurance
because i mean but you got to go all out
to get tired because the thing about the
heavy bag is
it can lull you into thinking you're in
shape because you pace yourself
you know so you need somebody to put
they haven't been out there
you got to go all out on a heavyweight
if you really want to be tired
because if not you just be hitting the
bag you know but so i play with the bag
um lift the weights um and then get on
the treadmill do sprints
um i do some elliptical um i do incline
bench
obviously rolls um you know pull downs
for back
um you know i do some upright rows i do
you know cur i do all the normal stuff
that we know about
it's just how you do it yeah it's just
how you do it and i never i also
try to make sure that i never get where
i can't move
yeah i want to be able to move because a
lot of guys they have candy muscles
right so it looks good but it's not
functional yeah and the guy has a big
chest we can't throw punches he can't
even get his arm across his damn chest
and he
he's he's so in shape but his candy
muscles you hit him in his chin
he'd go to sleep immediately you know
well that could be anybody but you know
what i'm saying like
you want to be functional you want to
have functional muscles absolutely you
know what i mean so i always
i always work at it from that point of
view making sure that i can i have
agility
i can move i can you know i can get on
the treadmill jump off do sprints you
know maybe i'll put the treadmill on
11.0
and we'll go for 30 seconds jump off
11.0
30 seconds jump off you know let you
know what i mean like things like that
then we'll slow it down maybe we'll go
with 8.0 at a two in con or three
incline you know me yeah so you know
put in um sonorian long distance runners
sonorian i want to show you something
okay that people um
they get up every day these mexicans
they get up every day and they run 200
300 miles you talking about the boring
the run like the boy in the run you know
about that book
no but you see that brother that does
that i want to be thieves no the sonoran
desert when he's mexican
yeah like 200 300 miles that's crazy
yeah that there's a book called born to
run that i started yeah
i'm doing that women men old men the
kids the babies the whole family some of
them do a barefoot
yeah barefooted some dude sandals on
yeah exactly yeah yeah
when i used to train right i used to say
god now how do we get in shape
and i used to do i used to um read about
the greek warriors achilles and all
these guys and what they did and i read
about xenophon the march of the 10
000. march 10th that much with 10
to be around what seventeen hundred
miles
something like that yeah yeah
the march to ten thousand that's crazy
yeah everything that's how we go [ __ ] so
i would just walk
i would walk to my gym work out and walk
back so that must have been
25 miles really yeah yeah that's crazy
yeah
i used to walk to the gym and walk to my
house from vegas i walked to the gym i
trained then i walked back
that's crazy i was i was smoking a lot
too though but i was saying this is what
these [ __ ] did these [ __ ] not better
than me
yeah but my feet felt like somebody took
a blow touch and put it on oh
man i did how did they get them that's
how they made marathon a guy a warrior
ran
25 26 point something miles gave the
message what was happening back then no
no what they what they did was the the
story of the story of marathon
they they actually ran the 26 points on
miles but they had to run back
in order to show to show that i believe
it was the um
not that that you don't call them
indians but the the indian um
empire i forget the persians persians to
show the persians that they were back
in time so they you know so that they
couldn't so those guys wouldn't invade
the cause
show about marathon let's get your [ __ ]
down let's get the reality of this [ __ ]
yeah that's just crazy uh that's crazy
is it the rara murray tribe
no no this one no i'm talking let's do
the greek one the history of marathon
how did marathon come about okay to run
a marathon
see they got this [ __ ] running right
wasn't it um philippines
he's the one that died right yeah
yeah the military victory against the
persons but go go to the actual battle
of marathon
um go go when they um when the actual
the soldiers had the
the march he had to battle the marathon
go to the battle marathon yeah yeah
i'm after the first persian invasion of
greece is fought between the citizens
exactly and persia was commanded by the
battle was culminates versus attempt by
persia yeah to subjugate greece the
greek armed decisively defeated the more
numerous persian making the turning
point
and the greco persian well yeah yeah
yeah exactly
exactly crazy and they they um they they
did a long march they had to do a long
watch
they fought one battle then they did a
long march back to protect
the the coast from the from the greek
navy i mean from the persian navy that
was coming in
so that was you know that was the thing
i i love that world histories of
charts that's what that's my that's my
hobby like that's all i love to do like
this i love that that's my hobby you
know what i'm saying like
though i love that yo it's funny mike
you like that [ __ ] too
that's funny that's good that's cool i
don't mean many people who are into it
like that well you want to go do you
want to go to the franks now i want to
go to clovis
charlemagne that's crazy what's your
what are you interested in right now
nice um i'm really interested know what
freaks me out that we allow um
indigenous people to be indigenous in
this world in time there's people that
have been on the island and senegal
for over 40 000 years and we didn't
civilize them yet yeah yeah and then
give them an oxygen now if they come to
they came here right now they die
because we're breathing on them and [ __ ]
people shouldn't live like this in this
day and time they should be nationalized
well you know what i i i beg to differ i
think that
people should have the right to live i
think that a lot of the problems in the
world have been created because
people want other people to live the way
they live i think you know what
it's it's it's mind your business no we
should be all civilized
no way there should be no uh
non-civilized people you think
i mean what is civilized i think it's
all perspective yes i look
i look no no it's not perspective this
is not this is my perspective
um i meet somebody and he picks he picks
his
p piss and throws piss in my face that's
not civilized
right and wanting to attack me for no
reason not civilized but you know what
people attack people for no reason in
the name of civilization
that's true too but i'm talking about
that that's from a big perspective that
means i'm coming to conquer your
gender i'm coming to conquer your
country and that part i'm coming to be
your friend i'm coming to civilize you
to my
brotherhood but you know what family
look what happened with you know you
think about indigenous people the story
they've been befriended and then con and
then yeah we're the indigenous people
you know why because
the problem with it is that you're i
understand what you're saying but
there's always somebody
who takes kindness for weakness there's
always gonna be somebody when i welcome
you in with open arms and say yes
you know like you know from what i
understand a lot of the american
original american indians didn't even
understand the on
the the idea of land ownership he's like
yeah this is mine now yeah okay they
didn't understand that what does that
even
mean like it's yours now this is our
land well no
no when they offered the buy they said i
can't sell you this is not mine they
offered to buy it
that's what i'm saying so it's like when
you think about it from that perspective
it's like
you know what people should have the
right to live how they want to live
um including including
and that includes everybody in other
words if you want to
wear a three-piece suit and have that
kind of a society and have a democracy
by all means you definitely should have
the right to do that but if you want to
be
in the jungle and you're happy and
you're drinking deer milk or whatever it
is and you
climbing trees for your food and killing
out and that's how you want to live you
should have the right to live that way
i don't great are you mike are you just
saying
so that people have access to modern
medicine and running water what if
they're happy excuse me what if they're
happy
yeah i mean maybe they don't know
they're not happy
but that's what i'm saying but what did
that maybe what's that but but ignorance
is bliss
if they're happy if they're happy yo
look if you have no right maybe they ha
their happiness is not the concept of
the idea of happiness but their
happiness with the concept of filth and
unsecurity and
disease but but you know what i'm like
but when they've been around
thousands of years and they feel
comfortable if they feel good
if they feel good being barefoot with
like some stuff around you know
i got a fur on my balls and you know i
gotta hey i tell you something
comfortable i get them used to it in 21
days
well that's habit that you're talking
about building habits yeah i understand
yeah you could build a habit over a
course of time that's just like working
out or
thinking a certain way of course i'm a
habit you're a habit all of us are happy
of course of course you're the sum of
habits yeah
but i think i think that look letting
people have the right
to live how they want to live look you
can find a positive on both sides right
you can have you got people who say you
know
af you know african society you know
some of the people who were sold out by
their own people and ended up in slavery
because it's not like
a white guy went over there said i'm
taking everybody it was there was people
that were
part of that process you know i'm saying
it's going to be very difficult for you
to just
go and take people from somewhere if
they don't want to go all right but
and i'm not saying they want to go in by
any means i'm just saying that there was
a whole process there right
that was horrifying and terrible and it
was the worst [ __ ] in the world
and you could say that now you have
people around the world who are
successful who become successful like
you know because of
their participation in european culture
or their participation
in some of the western things that go on
but what i'm saying is but the flip side
of that is
the flip side of that is you know what
there are people that are happy like you
talked about
you know it like that was it the mari
tribe was it the tribe that's on the
island that they shoot arrows at the
plains on the planet
is that it's underneath underneath yeah
they tried to go visit and they're just
hostile but you know no no but the maya
they've killed around seven people
visiting them already
but you know i don't want anybody
everybody who got visited ended up
getting [ __ ]
all right
if i'm here
this guy came over that religious guy
you know fanatic jesus loves you
oh they took him they wrapped a rope
around his neck and took him into the
woods hey yo mike i got news for you and
i believe
i believe in god i believe in god
completely i read the bible mike
a lot of people you know jesus loves you
yo absolutely came with that yeah and it
was something else that came behind it
so yo man the worst mistake you can make
is one for
kindness wow yo so there's a prime
example
so yeah let's let people live the way
they want to live man
don't get mad at them if they kill me or
anything because it's in the name of
jesus
but see but god ain't go i don't believe
that god is gonna tell you to go over
there and do no god's not a god ain't
gonna tell you to go
now i'm here to give you this because
yeah how are you gonna tell me i'm
unhappy
how are you gonna you gonna tell me i'm
unhappy yeah [ __ ]
you know i'm unhappy yeah you're gonna
tell me that i'm unhappy
i'm over here i'm on my island i'm
chilling you know what i mean i'm eating
my food that i've been eating for
thousands of years
you gonna come over here tell me i'm
unhappy and i need your rules
what made them stay there because some
people left
and they stayed it's just like the hood
mike it's just like the appalachians
it's people that are in west virginia
and the appalachians
who've been there for years and years
and have never left and the only
exposure that they have to the outside
world is through the media
through what's online through their
phones through through the internet
through tv
so none of them they beat with each
other brother no one say that i just
think something
i don't know no i would say that just
everybody doesn't think big
everybody doesn't you know everybody
doesn't wake up and think there's more
out there
everybody doesn't wake up and say yo
there's a bigger world out there you
have some people
they're just simple people there's
nothing wrong with them it's not that
they're any
necessarily dumber or smarter or worse
off or
it's just the spirit of some people is
you know what this is my
community this is where i live i'm home
and they're simple
like i'll give you an example i had a
wonderful experience i went out to ohio
i was out there hanging out talking
about different
doing some different stuff really simple
people in ohio there was very
you know it wasn't like new york and la
totally different spirit the middle of
the country
you know things different feels
different you know we talk about a lot
of fancy concepts and
you know in new york and la um but you
know in the middle of the country things
are a little
on certain levels are a lot simpler and
people aren't
thinking about all of that fancy [ __ ]
you know they're thinking about just
taking care of their families
making sure everybody's happy making
sure there's a meal on the table making
sure that kids get educated
making sure they have good work and they
feel good and that they can have some
enjoyment in life
and there's just some people that think
very very simply
and you know it's not you can't
necessarily criticize it
it's just a different way of thinking
you know new york and la we're very
sophisticated
you know east coast west coast i mean
look you got tv shows right
you got tv shows literally like like a
[ __ ] million people watching and they
get all the awards don't know you watch
this
[ __ ] nobody [ __ ] watches this [ __ ] b
and you get all the awards are you
[ __ ] kidding me
are you kidding me right now you you got
literally a million people watch this
[ __ ] and you get all the [ __ ] awards
and then you got shows where like 10 15
million people watching don't get [ __ ]
now what now come on well that's all the
system play that's how the system plays
that's what i'm saying
that's the difference that's the
difference that's what i'm talking about
on what the system you have all these
people that are very sophisticated
they're real fancy you know what i'm
saying they you know they they know this
they know that and then you got some
people that are very simple
yeah this is middle america this is a
simple these are simple folks
who just want to you know jobs just want
jobs and life
and love and happiness barbecues you
know hey
fourth of july and just keep it simple
yeah and you you got to respect both
i've learned to respect both yeah you
know what i mean i've learned to respect
both and and it
it really was an eye-opener for me
because you can forget
you can't forget that there are simple
people out there that just
working class normal people that are not
part of this fancy world that we live in
you know we we
you know we we have friends that are
billionaires and [ __ ] like that like
because people don't you know they're
not meeting
you know guys like that women like that
they're not meeting people like that
it's a whole different mindset that's
like another planet
you know and you have to remember that
well
on a very primal level i was primarily i
was taught to be those people
as a kid because i watched my mother i
watched my father watch some of them
live that life
nobody's life yeah you know what i
didn't want that's what it was called
then the nobody's life i didn't want
that nobody i didn't want that desperate
life when things were powered you had to
do desperate things that
you lose your [ __ ] pride over to get
food for the kids
yeah i didn't like that well that's a
different thing right because now you're
talking about you're talking about where
my survival yeah you're talking about
being deprived
that's a whole nother level like what i
was talking about is just the average
people
who are doing okay they're not doing
phenomenal but they're doing okay
now when you talk about inaudib when you
talk about poverty whether it's the
inner city or you talk about like
you know some of the some of the whether
it's the black community or some of the
southern white communities
where people just yeah where it's all
about survival and everybody's all
[ __ ] up and nobody has nothing you
know what i'm saying like
see the united states is funny [ __ ] me
up with that because i lived in ohio but
i didn't live in that world like
everything yeah yeah i wanted to
give [ __ ] exactly so so when you think
of mike though
huh i'm upset i mean i got a farm
60 minutes for 40 minutes from cleveland
i got a farm everything's good like
massive house everything looks great
over here the town is nice everything's
good
yeah but the regular people regular
people aren't living that [ __ ]
yeah they're not they don't have heated
marble floors the high school basketball
player is the biggest star
yeah you know and you got to respect so
i've learned you know he's always in the
paper the high school basketball player
and what i've learned man is that
you got to respect people for who they
are you know what i'm saying like you
got to respect regular people for being
regular people
and that's all right and i don't judge
people by by everybody doesn't get
judged by the same standards and rules
you know what i'm saying so when you
talk about the inner city or when you
talk about appellation when you talk
about people
you know where you met flint where
people with water problems you talk
about
people having issues with with nutrition
you talk about
no money i mean that's a whole nother
type of mentality too
that's another mentality don't got money
to see the doctor yeah it's crazy man so
you know we gotta like like even flint
like you talk about flint right like
there's really no reason
really no reason right now in the united
states of america at this day and age
while those people shouldn't have water
that [ __ ] is ridiculous yeah
you know what i'm saying like that [ __ ]
is crazy to me like that's
nuts to me that they're not like they're
not being taken care of that
that somebody hasn't gone in and really
taking care of that
it's unbelievable to me i think you find
money
in the government you figure it out you
find the funds you find the financing
even prime example and i don't know if
it was included but i understand that
they had this big disaster
relief um bill that passed or whatever
it was to get funding for some of the
disasters
natural disasters that have happened in
the u.s including puerto rico
i think that flint should have been
included in it oh yeah you know what i'm
saying and that could be
could the poor white kids the black they
should be included they're gonna be
included but they're not why
aren't they they're not everybody's
talking about they're not you know why
because everybody doesn't care about
everything
a lot of people you know you can always
you can always count on self-interest
a lot of people they base their
decisions including politicians
including even everyday people to a
certain extent they their decisions are
based on self-interest
fear and self-interest you know what i'm
saying and they make decisions based on
that
you know what i mean so so when you're
dealing with people that are making
decisions based on self-interest and
they having another agenda
they're not thinking about something
that's bigger than themselves
but if we had a if we have a government
or if we have a
of just people in general in positions
not to criticize our government
because they do some things right but
i'm saying if we have people in position
that that that think about the greater
good and think about
what what's best for all of us i think
that we would have a better
country and a better society you know
what i'm saying
yeah like i think that that's part of
what's missing well you know we're
seeing that turnover happening right now
as you were saying with this abortion
bill being passed
and it's really in my eyes it looks to
be the death throes
of the white supremacy it is you know it
is
it's they're clawing with their
fingernails everything they can
to hold on to this well you know people
that benefit from the old way
fight against the new way as much as
possible yeah you know what i'm saying
well listen um
i keep saying when you talk about the
white supremacy right what are they
going to do for when all the whites are
gone we still have all their um
we have their characteristics white
supremacy continues to go on in another
form well yeah well you always know
people are always going to you're right
mike
people are always going to find
something to separate us right if
everybody was
if everybody was blind and they'd be
talking about the people with big hands
versus small hands or goddamnit
high voices voices low voice they'd
figure something out
because people love to compartmentalize
make categories and put people in boxes
they just enjoy that and fear makes them
do that
because you have people that are afraid
that they're gonna go away people are
afraid
that oh you know you want our women or
you want our girls or you're not gonna
and
that is a a an unnatural fear it's a
it's a
a a knee-jerk response or reaction
rather
to fear you know what i'm saying it's
really like you know it's a lot of
fear-based [ __ ] going on so we just
gotta
i think look the more we could come
together as people
um the better i know that i know that in
the context of what's going on in the
world
that they may seem a little idealistic
and it probably is
but i do believe that there's some truth
in it that the more we can come together
the better off we'll all be yeah um and
i
what i'm not gonna let people do is i'm
not gonna let people
make me like hate all white people
because
there's one group that is on some kind
of weird mission
i'm gonna like judge people separately
and let people be who they are
you know just like every brother ain't a
brother you know what i'm saying like i
like so you know i'm everybody that
fights you is not your enemy and anybody
that helps you is not your friend
that's right that's right and sometimes
your enemies are your best friends
yeah you know what i'm saying and i say
that in the sense of not like your enemy
being your best friend but sometimes the
actions of your enemy
can turn out to be the most rewarding
and beneficial thing that's why
trader is the most hated person in this
planet because a traitor
he looks like you he dresses like you he
eats the same food you do
he says the same thing to his mother
that you say to your mother
but and even worse he convinced you that
he was with you
no exactly he does everything you do
yeah he makes you
you know you're comfortable everything
you do you believe he does yeah and how
did he be my enemy
and it's funny you say that because see
that's the other part of it about about
america that we have to remember that
that you know especially you know as
black people and it's tough because of
everything that goes on but we got to
remember that
if somebody invaded these shores we
still got to be there for this country
oh absolutely regardless so regardless
of
some of the the dirty laundry that we
have internally with some of the race
stuff at the end of the day
this is our country you know like you
know you got to love your country
like i'm not saying that it's all good
i'm not trying to whitewash it i'm not
trying to say
that you know i know you know i i know
i get all that i really do i get that
there's some bad [ __ ] that happens but
what i'm saying is
if boots hit the ground from another
place we have to be willing to defend it
we're not just going to lay back and say
okay y'all got it at least i would
no we can't you know what i'm saying i
wouldn't you know what i'm saying so
you know um i think that we all we
wanted to go to the world because we
wanted to convince the world we weren't
cowards
not only convinced people yeah no that
wasn't it yeah they said we were
carrying we weren't fit for war
yeah but but it's not fun and everyone
in this country well look look my family
fought and everyone in this country so
did my my grandfather was in the army
and my father's in the navy but you know
what is even deeper than that mike look
everybody in the world was slaves at
some point yeah
there's no ethnicity in the world that
wasn't slaves we just
you know it's just when you go back
thousands and thousands of years history
gets erased
and you know i always look at i always
look at race relations like
like franchises in sports right i have
this weird theory right
um you know the yankees are up they've
been up for a long time but there was a
time when they weren't or
so there are different races like
there's an ebb and flow of society
swinging of the pendulum so if you go
back to when the egyptians or you go
back to
even before the egyptians when the
nubians and you go back before that
the hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of years to the
to some of the king letters and cavemen
yo there was always
a ebb and flow of people so we can't get
you can't wake up in the morning and
feel like you're a loser
you know and you don't because everybody
everybody
in this world was a slave every
ethnicity was a slave at some point
believe me they were the slaves they
were prisoners of war they were
indentured servants
they were absolutely dominated at some
point
you go to britain you look at britain
but look what the romans did to brit
you know what i'm saying like you go i
mean you could go any i could point
and britain they got tunnels biggest
cities and stuff you know what i'm
saying that's going to point to any
country the romans
any ethnicity so you can't get caught up
in that you got to love yourself you
know me
yeah how do you what do you when you say
love that let's go back to love him why
do you love you
listen when some people say mike you
gotta treat yourself better all right
i'm gonna treat myself better
i'm gonna go through a [ __ ] audio
right i'm gonna go buy myself a great
[ __ ] suit
i'm gonna buy myself a rosewood is that
treating myself better let's treat
myself good going to a [ __ ] mental
health center
which one you know what you know what
it's it's what brings you look you could
only do what you knew how to do mike
exactly so when you were buying when you
were buying cars and crashing them and
throwing away i did the same thing
i bought a [ __ ] i bought a bm in
[ __ ]
in baltimore d.c area crash that [ __ ] on
farmers and [ __ ] it
just got out of here i did the same [ __ ]
i was [ __ ] but that's but i was only
dealing with the information that i knew
i didn't know no better so so happiness
and joy
and what's best for you is about do you
know any better you can only use the
information that you have
we couldn't have had this conversation
honey when we was hanging out don king's
house
how's your family again how's everybody
doing
[Applause]
though the kids are weird look at my son
my kids are weak
kids are weird no doubt man so you use
the information you got man
listen i watched you know i watched the
black guard father last night
classic i watched it it's amazing
amazing right but when he said
everything's numbered i disagree with
that okay tell me why
right he says everything's numbers okay
number your first numbers when you're
born your year you're born and then
you die some people don't know what year
they're born
suddenly listening didn't know where you
was born he didn't have the information
life is information well you know i've
always been a person with my belief life
is information yeah we would not know it
if it ends and start with numbers we
didn't have to make it
i would say i would say that you know i
understand what he's saying i've always
been i always hear people say like men
lie
women lie numbers don't that's true but
people lie with numbers
yes right so even though the numbers
don't lie
people can lie with numbers and listen
but right i mean look at enron
who out i mean i'm [ __ ] cool j who
the [ __ ]
is counting but that's my point yeah
that's my point
so so exactly so men like women line
numbers don't but yeah but who's
counting that's exactly my point so
you know i've never really totally
agreed with that i i understand the
concept and it is true
in its essence but it's it's a fact
but the truth is people lie with numbers
see there's a difference between facts
and truth
right there was a it was a it was a it
was a fact everybody thought that the
that the the sun revolved around the
earth but the truth was that the earth
revolved around the sun
right so the it's a fact that numbers
don't lie that they
it is even true but it's even more it's
also true that people lie with numbers
you see what i'm saying so you got to
you know you got to kind of take all
that with a great assault that being
said
i have supreme respect for claire um for
clarence
what he brought to the table and but he
brought to the cable now listen that's
that started a whole new um [ __ ]
dimension for us
look i wouldn't i have a song about
jingling [ __ ] yes my small jingling
baby would not
be i wouldn't have that song if clarence
didn't agree to clear it
you know because we sampled um dennis
coffey you know what i'm saying scorpio
so
i mean like the the reality is clarence
avon
is a is a giant amongst men and what he
was able to accomplish
um not being conscious of you know being
conscious of what it meant to be a black
man in america but still taking his life
to that next level and doing what he did
i mean that's un that's unheard of he's
unbelievable human being superman
he's amazing he should have been black
superman
and quincy jones who's a great friend of
mine um who you know
always you know instilled in me gave me
a lot of good advice and a lot of good
energy and
always showed me how to be classy i mean
i would walk in the house
i would walk in the house at mr jones's
house and he'd be sitting in there with
marlon brando talking you know and i'd
see him talking and
you know we'd be sitting at his kitchen
and you know he'd be having you know
baked potatoes on the phone before he's
pretty hard man
yeah yeah oh god yeah what was that like
you know tell me about no good
[ __ ] that's what he was telling
you about
don't trust these [ __ ] don't do
this and that why did you have a phone
that's funny
um who put me somebody put me on the
phone with them
i don't know some donkey somebody put me
on the phone right you talk to marlon
yeah my brother wants to talk to the
older man then he lived in that big old
mansion that he had
yeah but he was really he was really um
kind of interested kind of creepy and
[ __ ]
yeah what i saw him he was just cool he
was just chilling with mrs jones and
they was just in there talking i just
remember sitting there like fly on the
wall like tripping out like yo
like mr jones he took me to meet frank
sinatra you know what i'm saying and
like
you know i went to see frank um during
some of his last concerts in vegas yeah
he was playing atlantic city too yeah
and he was like you know hey quinn hey
quincy you have any problems you call me
i'll call
ll he'll break somebody's legs for you
you know man like yo
yo i met him like 90 when i was on top
of my thing right
through my little thing 90 i'm mike
tyson so he was talking to me he's happy
he was talking something looking
like i'm like i'm [ __ ] looking at him
like this and so he gets it right
and then he says to me um before he
leaves he's talking some people right
and i'm watching him and before he
leaves he walks by me and he said listen
let me explain something to you kids how
good you're doing it's how is how long
you're doing good
[Applause]
see that's the real [ __ ] i'm talking
about right there
it's not how good you're doing this how
good how long you're going doing good
yeah
you know what's funny because when we
was walking we was walking he said to me
when he was walking towards us
he was nice to me he was really nice he
said look at them nice to me check me
but then i ran into him again he was
sick he wasn't feeling good
and they wanted to take a place he said
mike get over there mike get might get
you get over here man
and that's whoa okay yeah that's when i
saw that part of myself
[ __ ] yeah that's crazy yup that's a trip
yeah that's funny i remember we was
walking to the dressing room
and um he said to me he said you know
stick with me kid i'm the guy you came
to the dance with
no one said yeah go home with the person
who came to the dance floor that's the
only
thing yeah yeah go home with the person
you came to the dance floor you came to
the dance with like yo i'm like yo frank
sinatra is cool man
you know he was the man back then you
know and he was human you know
they showed things that they never
showed about his relationship with god
and he was just so overwhelmed
[ __ ] whipped over he just couldn't oh
he was [ __ ] dead
that she could do anything to him but
she felt that she was entitled to
because she felt she took care of him
and then when she took care of him he
went back with these guys like these
guys the one that drained and put him in
this situation
for me to take care of him and yeah she
saw him at his weak moments and
sometimes when women see you weak
whoa that's not healthy it's definitely
not i don't allow my yeah i don't allow
that to happen
it's definitely not yeah my wife gets
angry but i don't let her see me
that in a minute that dad we've been
lonely yeah yeah
yeah you don't want to you don't want to
do something too much of that boohoo
you know she do too much of that she saw
him weak she saw him winking so she
played oh that was a problem and and
then in general
look we all have vulnerable moments but
you should in general be strong
yes too you know what i'm saying like
you should be strong
yeah know what the woman the woman don't
want to have to she don't want to be the
head of the [ __ ] family
definitely not they're so used to that
and you know i think a man
i think a man needs to be on his purpose
first too exactly and you got to be on
your mission your mission got to be
first and your purpose got to be first
you know what i'm saying and you can't
put anything in front of your mission
and your purpose
and your dreams and you can't you know
what you don't want to do is put
yourself in a position where
you're tiptoeing and crawling behind a a
woman who you love
as opposed to putting your mission and
your purpose first because if you put
your mission and your purpose first
you'll be able to take care of your
family you'll be able to take that's why
i like on a plane they say put your
oxygen mask on first
and then take care of the person next
time you're gonna take care of you take
care of your mission and your purpose
first you know what i'm saying take care
that first then we'll deal with
you know and then by doing that you'll
be able to take care of the woman you
love and your family you know what i'm
saying but be a man
be a man first you know what i'm saying
don't you know you don't have to be a
boohoo
cry baby [ __ ] yeah you guys having
this conversation no listen stemming
from frank sinatra
no because he was a man's man when we
think about him though
he was a man's man but a woman still
broke him yeah okay
it
but women still had them underneath
crying yeah it could happen it could
happen it can happen but
you know what you just don't want to do
that we all gonna do that you know we
all do that
well you know but i mean look men and
women have been like that for thousands
of years right i mean men
you know you know a woman gets pregnant
you know
nine months you know man you know you
could have you know
90 babies in 99 months you know what i'm
saying so it's a it's a different
mentality and a different form of
existence women are more
going to be more selective in who they
deal with men and like
visually men get stimulated visually as
soon as they see someone i like that
women you know it's an emotional how do
we control our visualization and reality
by understanding realization
i tell you by by allowing that energy to
influence you and inspire you in
different ways like just because you see
a girl that's attractive
doesn't necessarily mean you have to
have a you could let that that
attraction and that that that vibe
inspire you you know what i'm saying you
could just take it as inspiration you
don't necessarily have to
have her you know what i'm saying i'm
not saying that you should or shouldn't
that's up to every guy to make his own
choice but i'm saying
you don't necessarily have to have her
you know you can let that energy and
that spirit and that beauty inspire you
and move and and and get you to want to
go to new heights
you know what do they say a man who can
conquer himself is stronger than a man
who can conquer her city right
yes because because you got you know
when it's right there in front of you
it's like the cookie jars right there
it's just like you know can you what can
you do can you conquer you
but that's a look that's up to nobody's
perfect i don't want to
try to talk from a pedestal we've all
been there done some crazy [ __ ] in our
lives including me
but i would say that you know what you
want to do is you just want to use that
as inspiration
and just have that real strength you
know what i mean yeah that's what i was
saying
i mean i think there's a lot of men out
there though who feel that way that mike
feels and it's like what you're saying i
think listen people look at it from an
intimate learning
culture yourself yeah right you gotta
know that because that's part of
harnessing that
masculine energy that's what i'm saying
you can harness the masculine energy
you don't necessarily have to have her
you can use that energy to push you
to new heights yeah you know what i'm
saying it's i guess i know that's what
we'll call it sexual trance no but this
is something that that's not written in
books you know
yeah when when a man and a woman have
sex in a way it's kind of a
psychological emotional it's a war
going on and listen and the woman knows
when she runs
of course just like you know when you
won and you know what they know when you
want to right right
everybody knows someone's going to win
well it's very simple yeah
if you're not on your purpose if you're
not on your purpose and you're not on
your mission
then you've lost yes all right if you're
look no woman is going to be happy with
you chasing our ass all the time
like all the time i'm not talking about
in the beginning when you guys are
coming together i'm talking about
if you live your life chasing a woman
and showing up at her doorstep and
having flyers and [ __ ] and violence and
you know all that [ __ ] you're killing
yourself yeah the relationship is not
gonna last
yeah you know what i'm saying you have
to be confident enough but there's some
women that love it
i've been there with some little women
love being spoiled getting everything
and then soon you [ __ ] you don't
stimulate oh my god this nigga's sick
but that's what i'm saying
but that was my point yeah mike that's
my point okay
and that that's my point it's like it
does it doesn't work
it doesn't work so fellas i you know i'm
just gonna give you some advice
all that chasing that [ __ ] don't work no
if she want to be look if she wants to
be with you
you she'll be with you believe me all
that chasing [ __ ]
you're killing yourself i promise you
and listen i guarantee you i bought all
this [ __ ]
not that i didn't think i put it down
and she like she didn't like the way i
made love to her so it was i wasn't cool
no i didn't it
it wasn't a good energy and it's only to
it's not only to make love the reality
is you when you buy your way in
and you become a provider and you just
become like a like you represent
provision
that's not the same as being sexually
stimulating exactly
like representing provision and just
being a guy yo i'm gonna buy you a bunch
of [ __ ]
you know that that's weak i got it i'm
not gonna have nobody
guys they use money guys that use money
never do guys that use money to
to sustain their relationships and use
money to get their way in
me that's weakness it's weak because you
don't believe in you enough
you you're trying to use money yeah yeah
you got to be
you the money the money is an
exclamation mark the money makes you
more of whatever you already are
but you got to bring something to the
table absolutely you know what i'm
saying it's not about i never wanted to
bring anything to the table
yeah that's a you want the easy way yeah
i want the easy way the easy way i'll
get you in but it ain't no relationship
in it yeah or unless
she just wants the provision yeah unless
she just wants to be provided before but
but but guess what
when you're the guy that's providing the
money and all that what she's going to
do is
she's going to get a silverback gorilla
to tear ass up
on yourself because you're not bringing
the stimulus i would know
i used to believe i used to believe
gorilla
you know what i mean you could be the
silverback gorilla or you could be the
[ __ ] guy who's you know yeah
i thought that both bro they had both
sides both sides
you know i mean [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ]
that's just one to grow on let's just
want to grow
how much time do you have do you have
some time i mean [ __ ] i've been here
three days you mean that okay i'm good
i'm great
i'm having fun i'm good i mean i don't
know how you're going to add this whole
thing at once but
no this gotta be a three-parter we do
this stuff yeah yeah it's amazing
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah and i
didn't want to talk about the what are
they talking about i'm talking about
rock the bells um like give me the
sweatshirt all right
rock the bells rock the bells radio um
yeah i listen to it every day when we
get here
this is um yes yeah
that's the um that's the uh classic
music on radio
classic it's a cloud and in the front it
says strictly for og
rocket bells is a classic hip-hop
station he's dedicated to classic
hip-hop so yeah
let's do it let's do while we come here
channel 43 on siriusxm
people should check it out you know what
i'm saying i program every song that's
the thing people don't know
i pick every song i pick all the
commercials i pick over
yeah i play rock ham i play everybody
big daddy kane
nwa dre snoop i mean every classic hip
hop
artist everything from the 2000s and
before is all playing on rock the bells
on siriusxm
so people should check that i thought
everybody knew this [ __ ] that they you
know they don't know i know
your fans probably don't know but now
you know channel 43 sirius xm
no doubt oh yeah i know they are they
all they are but you know what they
might not be what
be it might not be on their radar yeah
you know what i'm saying so now you know
channel 43 serious excellent you know
yep something else you're doing man yeah
it's crazy yeah yeah yeah
so tell us how did you feel about the
[ __ ]
um star thing on the walking face that's
accomplished [ __ ] you know it was not
too many black people on that [ __ ] you
know there's actually a picture of me
when i was a little kid
i came out to la and i stood on the star
and there was no name on a star i just
picked the star me and my crew stood on
it right
it was an amazing time but there's a
picture of me um
you know on the walk of fame and um
man that was just a hell of a feeling
man just to to know that you made that
kind of an impact you know
yeah dude you know that kind of an
impact man is an amazing feeling
yeah it's an amazing feeling man shout
out to everybody who's there puffing
magic johnson latifah
russell you know um just i want to send
love to the whole walk of fame you know
what i'm saying
it's an amazing feeling elle you're
really you're like an american treasure
dude
i'm grateful yeah i'm grateful man you
know i'm grateful you know it's funny i
think that we all
the universe is funny like i think about
me sitting here with mike
many years later and i'm looking at you
and i think about how you inspired some
of my early albums were like
i'm bad and you know i said i'm like
tyson i sent him a soldier award say
your name in the record and all that
and i think about how if you wasn't a
little kid from brooklyn that bust your
ass and did what you did how i would
have never had that line
and i think about fast forwarding to us
sitting here
and it's funny how how like as it's like
a solar system and certain people
revolve
yeah and just you know what i'm saying
do you know what i mean
like this is what i said about we all
we're all um like they did seven degrees
of separation
yeah with um this stuff we become more
um
how do i express it we become more
connected with those people
yeah we're even more from like a one
degree separation because we get to know
who they are from this
yeah which we've never known before the
information that this give us
so yeah we're all one with everything
amazing
i was thinking about that when you guys
were talking about both meeting frank
sinatra
yeah how interesting that is yeah sam
you ever meet sammy davis i never met
sammy no
no never miss sammy but his family
his wife and kids i i believe were from
in the neighborhood in queens
yeah they had a place in queens as well
and um but you know i
like meeting um jackie robinson's wife
you know
um amazing i was at the airport i'm
talking to her i met some unbelievable
people over my i mean
his children just people i know like
barbra streisand very interesting people
i know that
you wouldn't think like you know there's
a whole world out there
you know what i'm saying well it's
amazing man how you've your music
that's like its whole own amazing
storyline then your movies acting
like i loved deep blue sea yeah yeah
that was fun love
any given sunday thank you two of my
favorite movies you got a memory play
you played god i knew yeah
yeah in too deep yeah into deep was a
lot of fun oh dude i mean shout out to
omar epps how did you get to acting
you know what it was i'll tell you the
real story here's how i go first of all
when i was a little kid i always
loved acting uh you know we used to like
get the camcorder out and i'd be like
pretending i was bruce lee because you
know bruce lee was like you know he
wasn't a black guy but he wasn't white
and he was like a superstar in the film
it was like inspiring anywhere
like jim kelly and all these guys and he
was super cool and he inspired me to
want to do
movies not necessarily acting per se but
to be
in that position in movies on screen so
i used to walk around on jamaica avenue
with my chinese slippers on and my game
of death suit
everybody you know you know i mean so i
love bruce so
what happened was when i was making
music there was a certain point first of
all i was always exposed to the agents
and music just because of the
i mean in film because of the business
so i had music agents and they were at
agencies and they were acting agents and
stuff like that
but the real thing is one time i went um
the real story is one time i went
and um so funny russell don't even
notice i sat with russell
and i was like russell um you know i
wanted to get in advance on one of my
albums i don't remember which one it was
but
russell had said um uh well you know and
i you know he had his business whatever
he was doing but he was like
he like shifted his weight in his chair
and i was saying to myself you know what
the way he shifted his weight in this
chair this [ __ ] i might be in a position
i'm begging in a few years i said i
ain't with this [ __ ]
i went out and started focusing on
acting because i i wanted to i didn't
want to limit myself
you know what i'm saying so i got with
quincy jones and and mr jones put me on
and put me on the tv show
um that obviously i'd been in films
before that but that was my first real
foray into the acting world on a
permanent level what was the first thing
um the very first thing i did was crush
groove and then after that i was in
wildcats which was wesley snipes and
um and um woody harrison's first movie i
had like a bit part cameo in that
and then after that i did toys with
robin williams and michael gambon and
all those people
i did the hard way with james woods but
but i moved into the
to to the tv because i just didn't want
to have limits
yeah i didn't want to i'm a big believer
that you you can't limit yourself
the cunning hair has more than one boro
you know what i'm saying the smart
rabbit has won more than one hole
and i i don't want to limit myself if
you have talents you use them
you don't you don't like ignore certain
talents that you have because of fear or
whatever
so even though i loved music and still
loved music i wanted to do more
i just simply wanted to do more i i had
no desire at that time to be an
executive i had no desire to
do anything but pursue my dreams and one
of them was to be in films
and tv and doing that plus it it put me
in a position where it freed me up
i didn't need nobody you know what i'm
saying and now i'm in a life now where
you know
i can take my ball and go home like i
don't need and i like i
i don't get me wrong i need people in
terms of life and humanity but
i'm all right you know what i'm saying
i'm all right you know what i'm saying
i'm thankful and
and that was part of it that was the
process that's awesome man
you know what are your dreams these days
yeah when it's all over what you want
said and done well that's two different
there's two different questions in terms
of dreams
like i believe i'm a big believer when
you're pregnant with a dream you don't
open up your womb and show it to the
world you'll kill a baby you know what
i'm saying so
i have dreams i never limit myself and
i'm still dreaming
in terms of what i want people to
remember i just want people to just
look at my body of work and how it
impacted the world and then they could
judge for themselves
but i want to be a positive impact on
the world and i want to do more like
right now i'm enjoying like rock the
bells because not only because of like
and i'm not just saying some selling
promotional [ __ ] i'm saying i enjoy it
because
i'm serious i sell this because i i
i enjoy the idea that you have these
these artists that were forgotten that
were marginalized that aren't at the top
of the pop charts right now
that may not necessarily be the the
hottest thing in social media but you
know what
they're being respected again and
they're being put in a position again
and people are loving their music and
have access to this that's how i feel
about the old fighters
you know what i'm saying yeah exactly
like you know floyd's a great fight
don't get me wrong yeah you know he had
50 fights and he said deal
listen sugar ray robinson had 47 fights
he lost one then he had 78 fight
then he had a 78 fight winning streak
yeah but you even even
had 47 lost one in 78 winning but even
more
it was even more modern look at julio
says
he was 88 84-0 right 89
so don't tell 99-00 about you the
greatest fight with 50 you know [ __ ]
you're great no doubt about him
at 90. yeah he's fighting for he's
fighting like what eight times a year
yeah it's it's it's more than whatever
for them whoever's in the rankings
i think there are more metrics and more
measurements that have to be made
i think who's the greatest is subjective
like you know like
mike is obviously one of my favorite
fighters for real not just because i'm
sitting here
for real yeah you know like and i think
any guy my age would probably feel in a
similar way but i also like roy jones
i think roy jones [ __ ] i think
yeah he got that's what i'm saying he
got clipped later on
but you know so so losing doesn't
necessarily define whether you're great
or not
because a lot of people like a lot of
people lose it's you know you just
it just it is what it is but greatness
is defined
it's a lot of different ways to define
it it's not only just the win loss
record
i get it i respect that 100 percent
but if you fight long enough and if you
don't measure it you're going to lose at
some point
you know what i'm saying it's just a
matter of time so you know look marciano
retired undefeated
marciano retired undefeated he died got
made recipes died in a plane crash
he was you know amazing he was 49-0 i
mean it has happened before
you know what i'm saying the the
greatness to me
is the whole body of work the saga
the the fights the the the getting on
the canvas they're getting up there's a
lot of different things that come into
play
but that being said look i respect
everything that floyd has accomplished
like
i really respect i'm not gonna say look
at the end of the day
people can say what they want about
floyd as far as his life but he's a
[ __ ] winner
and you gotta yo you gotta respect that
you can you can talk that [ __ ] all you
want but you gotta respect that but
that being said there's a lot of great
fighters i mean you know watching what
he did this great i'm talking about his
real his early fights like all of
the crazy [ __ ] i seen him do i i
remember like even though it wasn't
super early but like even
burbank you know what i'm saying like
that moment watching this dude like
this dude like and oh that being said
let me just say this
that's the other thing about fighting
anybody that laces those gloves up
and puts them boots on and walks in that
ring deserves respect i don't care if
they got knocked out in the first round
or never knocked out because you know
what
the balls and the courage that it takes
and you putting your life on the line
that's a whole nother level yeah you
know what i'm saying that's a whole
nother level
and like like i'll give you an example
like like and look
you all have fights and he got the bet
it was a different time in your life
different time in your life
but even linux lennox is one of my
favorite fighters he's a great fighter
different error from you even though you
all are similar in age
the curve of your career was different
he met you at a different time
but i still respect linux like you know
what he did to david tour
you know what i'm saying but you got to
respect two or two though you see what
i'm saying yeah so
so the craft the the art of boxing and
the spirit of boxing
is not about like wins and losses it's
there's a bigger there's a bigger story
i think there
which is the spirit of the violence we
don't look like how many fights you want
to look we
said what happened to you what did you
do you know what happened to what
happened
you know what i mean even though you
became a great fighter at the end of the
game did you
you leave here [ __ ] up and [ __ ] right
and plus
it's balls too right so here's the other
thing
the the the win-loss thing the thing
about the win loss and the undefeated
thing
is that you know the guys with balls
the bigger the balls the more likely
you're going to lose yeah because you're
going to keep going
yeah you know what i mean it's like
that's like they weren't like how
[ __ ] like
you're a real intellectual real smart
person like like let's say a martial or
floyd maybe you stop
early you're like even lennox to a
certain extent was one of those that
he i think he beat everybody that he
ever got in there with eventually even
though he lost like to mccall and he
lost to
um uh haseem rahman he he he um
was able to write those losses but he
even stopped
earlier it seems to me like the guys the
more courageous guys
the the ali's you know the mics they
keep going no but you gotta look at
these guys the guys that keep going we
keep going but we do
out of money a lot of times we do it out
of the money sometimes
a guy like ali right ali do it because
he believes that no one could beat him
that's what i'm saying he believes no
one can be that's what i'm saying that's
the courageousness yeah
that's the correction some guys fight
just for money to get some money but
this guy fights because they don't
believe nobody could be that's what i'm
saying
it's a totally different situation
that's a hell of it for money
and fight for guys no i could [ __ ]
say so prime example so a guy like that
you can't really look at win losses
because there's something else there
there's a there's a an indomitable
spirit there no no
with a guy like that you have to be
careful you have to watch him because
yeah he won't stop you have to kill him
for him to lose he won't quit
i'll leave one now ali was unbelievable
they did that lego like this no i don't
want to fight no one you know
you got to kill him such pride
[ __ ] such in [ __ ] um ability to
love himself
wow [ __ ] it's crazy unbelievable you
think about listening and you think
about
frasier and those guys you know like
listening was like
so unappreciated you know and the way he
passed away he died they say he got
killed overdosed like
i mean he didn't even do drugs but he
did some cocaine but listen listen that
smacked the [ __ ] out of our lady before
he was talking [ __ ] and he smacked the
[ __ ] out of him now he's [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] wow
oh he has left ali left the [ __ ] ran
out of place
yo listening with something else big
hands
hell of a fighter
nobody is a mean [ __ ] but listen
with the real thing you know like some
guys out here they get in the paper
listening was knocking the cops out
breaking that just knocking so when it
comes to a town listen come to
philadelphia so to speak
he's in philadelphia the cops made a
call they come to the train station the
bus station wherever yet
you can't come here you get on the bus
and leave they won't let them faint lose
you can't come in the cops at the
train station get on the bus and leave
they won't let them come into the states
that's for formidable mean son of a
[ __ ]
and he happened to be a fighter it's a
meme right
but
you can have a killer ins a killer
instinct and a mean spirit you got five
minutes out
i'm looking at you okay a killer
instinct and a mean spirit of
two different things so i see the lady
love thing going on over here you got
the lady um assistant
it's your team that's my team that's the
team there they all they're all working
i'll be so afraid my woman my wife would
kill me and stuff
why what you don't want me don't be
around the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
because she knows who i was at one time
my wife loves me to death my wife my
wife are killing that my wife don't
trust me
you shouldn't trust me yeah yeah you
know she should try well i'm trustworthy
now but
she shouldn't trust well my wife is
gonna have to yeah she's gonna have to
well she's gonna
complain i know my wife can't don't
trust yeah trust me she's gonna have to
trust me because
i want that oh i love that [ __ ] i'm just
not
well man you're such coming from a big
perspective i came from a pig
perspective at one time and i'm
cleaning my life up no your life is
cleaned up man
congratulations on this cannabis thing
yeah i mean this is this
is the pick yeah that's the pick of me
on the stall like before
before um yeah show it to the camera
before i um
before i had a star that's the picture
of me like on the star you know what i'm
saying like wanting to get on the star
like that was us dreaming of the stars
visualizing
those other people and cut
what happened to the kid from california
is the bobcat man that's what
we're gonna have to get it on the next
next round all right we'll get it
yeah get it this is a crazy picture
that's dope hell you're the man bro
man hey man you want to shout out
anything you need anybody know anything
about everybody no
no just hit me up ll cool j on all the
social media
and um rocket bells yeah rock the bells
channel 43 series xm dope [ __ ]
um check out lip sync battle you know on
the paramount network
ncis los angeles society doing that too
you still get paid
that runs yeah yeah yeah i participate
in the business i'm doing okay i can get
a cheeseburger
you know me you know i'm working on
steak but i could definitely get a
cheeseburger
i could definitely get a cheeseburger
that's good man so listen what is one
and thirty zeros how much money is that
let's put that there thirty years
thirty zero yeah let's see what that is
well [ __ ] i was looking at them
and somebody showed me that and what it
was is that a trillion
no it's super thrilling super big
supplement million i forgot what is it
one in 30 zero
[ __ ] what does it say um it's a trillion
what is this
one super super billion zillions what
the
[ __ ] is you had it on the page before
that i know
it was it was cut off well i thought
numbers let's say one
one trillion right there one with 24
zeros is a quintillion
quintillion one with 30 zeros go up
sextillion
sextillion sextillion so we have to get
sextillion
no doubt no
questions no question man thank you so
thank you man thanks for having me man
appreciate you awesome love man yeah
mike love man love man appreciate you
man no doubt
mike great episode thanks for listening
[Music]
everybody